Okay.
I have an anecdote for you.
That's really all it is.
But it's an interesting one in a sense about
the failures of our healthcare system.
Although I know that this is both number one
relatively minor in the grand scheme of things
and that I'm fortunate enough to be in a position
not to be crippled financially by what I'm
about to tell you.
And it's also not a serious health issue.
Okay.
So here's my medical background on this particular
story.
Years and years ago I was having knee pain
when I would run and when I would bike and
when I would play basketball and my doctor
said, it seems like it's more than just, you
know, you're not 19 anymore.
You should go and see a podiatrist and see
what's going on.
It could be related to your feet.
So like 10 years ago or something, I went
to a podiatrist and the podiatrist said, Yup,
your knees and ankles are not correctly aligned.
We need to correct your arches with some orthotic
insoles.
A, she made me the insoles obviously in the
United States, the insoles themselves were
not covered by insurance.
So I bought the in souls and paid my copay
for the podiatrist.
And I've had those in soles for a year and
over time, uh, for many years, over time,
the insole start to flatten out just from
the weight of the person wearing them.
Uh, and I was starting to have knee pain again.
So I wanted to go to a podiatrist, get a new
evaluation, find out if I need new insoles,
uh, and also have them look at my feet.
I have something called Greek feet hilariously,
where the second toe is longer than the big
toe and it can sometimes scrunch that second
toe and uh, create some weird stuff on the
front of the foot and the nail.
So I wanted that looked at as well.
Okay.
So I made an appointment with my podiatrist.
I did all of the right things.
I have insurance.
The insurance is a totally normal middle of
the road.
What's called a silver plan, meaning that
my specialist copays are $40.
This is where the big insurer here in Massachusetts
called Tufts health plan.
I don't know if people around the country
know about Tufts health plans.
It's a pretty big insurer here.
So I do all the right things.
I call my insurance.
I say, does my plan cover podiatry, David?
Yes, it does.
Great.
Uh, which podiatrists this my insurance cover.
Here's a list.
Great.
Do I need a referral from my regular doctor
to see a podiatrist?
No, you don't.
You just call the podiatrist and make an appointment.
Fantastic.
Do I need pre authorization from you, my insurance
in order to have the visit covered?
No, you don't.
David, you just go.
If it's someone on our list, we will cover
all but the copay.
Perfect.
I make the appointment.
I go, the doctor sees me for 10 minutes.
Okay.
10 minutes says, David, your arches are flat
so you need new insoles.
We don't make insoles here.
Here's a prescription for how the insole should
be made.
Go to this other place.
The insurance is not going to cover the insoles.
The insoles are going to be $375 but your
toes look fine.
Nothing to worry about there with your Greek
feet.
Perfect.
I take my prescription, I pay my $40 copay
and I'm on my way.
Two weeks go by and I get a bill for $414
from the podiatrist.
Now how could this be?
I paid my $40 copay.
I didn't need authorization, I didn't need
a referral.
Podiatry is covered.
I went to a podiatrist covered by my plan.
Well, it turns out, uh, that podiatry is covered
and I didn't need a referral and I didn't
need preauthorization.
But the diagnosis of flat feet is not covered.
And that is how I was diagnosed.
And therefore io $454 for the visit minus
the $40 copay or $414.
So I say, wait, hold on a second.
I went in for knee pain.
How should I know in advance what the diagnosis
is going to be?
My insurance says that simply not our problem.
So anyway, I was able to speak to someone
who said what you should do is call the doctor
and ask if this is definitely wink, wink,
the right diagnosis.
Now of course someone at Tufts health plan
can't say, David, let me help you commit insurance.
Call the doctor and ask for a different diagnosis
so that we will cover them.
Obviously they can't do that, but I'm reading
between the lines and they say, this is the
system we have.
I would call the doctor's office and explain
the situation.
So I called the doctor's office and I explained
and they say, oh, we're going to get someone
to talk to the doctor.
Maybe the doctor can rebuild this some other
way, maybe focusing on the Greek feet part
or some other diagnosis other than flat feet.
So at this point, again, fortunately this
is more a curiosity for me.
Can I ultimately get this covered?
I may well end up paying three 75 for the
insults, four 14 for the visit, plus my $40
Copay, right?
That's $829 in addition to my monthly insurance
premium of $425 a month to get insults.
Okay?
In other countries in souls are 100 bucks
and the podiatrist themselves makes them and
it would be a fraction of the cost.
So understand that part of the inefficiency
here is look at the number of people that
are involved with this 10 minute specialist
visit.
I spoke to one insurance person before making
the visit a appointment to figure out what
is and what isn't covered.
I spoke to another insurance person after
I saw the doctor.
I was then checked out at the office by someone
in the billing department to pay for my copay.
I then called and spoke to someone in the
finance office for the podiatrist who then
will go back and speak to the doctor and the
care supervisor.
We're up to seven six people being spoken
to in seven different interactions and they
may end up rebilling this some other way.
How much of the gap between the hundred dollars
this would have cost in other countries?
Maybe one 50 to the hundred to the eight 29
that in total I'm going to pay how much of
that nearly $700 difference is related to
the fact that I spoke to six different people
about billing related issues and again, I'm
lucky that this isn't serious and that I can
afford it.
If I end up having no choice but to pay eight
29 total for this ridiculous fiasco, I'll
be okay.
That's not the case for a lot of people who
can't afford an unexpected $400 expense.
And then of course there's the broader question
of why would a 10 minute visit to a podiatrist
even be priced at $454 which is again related
to all of the bs that is part of the system,
inefficiencies, bureaucracy, billing, coding,
a nonpayment from people who don't have insurance
and ultimately are just going to skip out
on the bill.
It is truly a perverse system and I don't
want to make my story seem any more important
than it is.
I tell it merely as an anecdote that I have
a send me your thoughts.
If you have a similar story, please post it
in the comments for the youtube video for
this segment.
I do want to hear from you about it.
Okay.